[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
>> Laura: COMMODITIES AND GET
THAT MUCH BETTER.
BUT OUR NEXT GUEST IS A TRUE
URBAN COWBOY.
DALE AND SWEARINGEN GREW UP IN A
LITTLE TOWN IN NEW YORK.
I DON'T OFTEN THINK OF NEW YORK
AS THE BALL RAN CAPITAL THE
WORLD, BUT LAST YEAR HE WAS
CROWNED WORLD CHAMPION.
HE JOINS ME NOW ALL RIGHT
HONESTLY I INTERVIEW A LOT OF
POLITICIANS COME IS MY FAVORITE
INTERVIEW ALL RIGHT THIS BETTER
BE GOOD.
HOW TO HECK DID YOU DO THIS?
WHAT?
OUTSIDE OF BUFFALO?
YOU END UP WINNING IT ALL I'VE
HAD A CHANCE TO WATCH A BULL
RIDING IT IS SO EXCITING AND SO
DANGEROUS AND TERRIFIES ME.
>> YES, MA'AM, IT'S ALWAYS
ENTERTAINING.
IT'S ALWAYS SOMETHING NEW
HAPPENING THAT'S FOR SURE.
>> Laura: HOW DID YOU BECOME
THE FIRST NEW YORKER TO WIN AT
THIS LEVEL IN BULL RIDING?
>> YOU KNOW, THERE'S JUST A LOT
TO RODEO WING IN NEW YORK PEOPLE
THINK OF THE CITY AND
EVERYTHING, BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
RODEO OUTSIDE OF THAT SO MY
FAMILY IS HERTA GROVES DOING IT
I WENT TO TEXAS DOING COLLEGE.
AND THEN SCAN LIVED OUT HERE
THIS, DOING IT I JUST GOT UP AND
ARE ON RIGHT PEOPLE.
BUT GETTING THROWN OFF AGAIN
RIGHT BACK UP THAT'S FOR SURE.
>> Laura: NOW THE SPORT SEEMS
TO BE EXPLODING IN POPULARITY
CEO OF THE PROFESSIONAL BULL
RIDING RIDER IS SAYING RECENTLY
THAT A CROSS THREE EVENTS THIS
WEEKEND NEW YORK CITY, PORTLAND
AND LEXINGTON PPR HAD THE SINGLE
BUSY REGULAR-SEASON OF TICKET
SALES AND ATTENDANCE AND ITS
HISTORY.
ACROSS THREE CITIES THEY HOSTED
A TOTAL OF 64,000 PEOPLE
WATCHING.
WHY IS THIS GOING A POPULARITY?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO
POPULARITY BECAUSE IT'S MAN
VERSUS BEAST THAT HAS TO PLAY
OUT.
THERE'S NO WHISTLES ONCE THEY
GATE OPENS ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
IT COULD BE A GREAT RIDE, A GOOD
WRECK.
THE POSSIBILITY ARE ENDLESS.
>> Laura: 2023?
HOW IS YOUR BACK?
>> IT'S GOOD, I'M FEELING GOOD.
>> Laura: I'M WATCHING THIS
FUND ON A WYOMING I GO TO THE
RODEO CAKE WHICH MARK THERE
ALREADY ROPING EVERYTHING BUT
WHEN I'M WATCHING THE BASEBALL
RIDERS NOTHING THINKING OF HIS
LOWER BACK, DISKS NECK IF YOU
GET TRAMPLED ONE TIME THE WRONG
WAY PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE HOW
INCREDIBLE HE DANGEROUS IT IS
HOW MUCH IS THE AVERAGE BULL
WAY?
>> PROBABLY WAS ABOUT 18,
1500 POUNDS.
SO DEFINITELY BIG IN THEIR WAY
STRONGER THAN YOU THINK.
THEY ARE CREDIBLE ATHLETES
THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: WAS THE WORST INJURY
YOU'VE RECEIVED?
>> YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN PRETTY
HEALTHY I'VE HAD SOME SURGERIES
AS ARE PROBABLY LIKE THE LONGEST
SETBACKS I'VE BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE.
>> SURGERIES FOR WHAT?
SO MAYBE PULL OUT IF YOU COME ON
SURGERIES FOR WHY?
>> WIDE SURGERIES ON MY
SHOULDER, HIP, MY JOB.
>> Laura: YOU ACTED LIKE YOU
NEVER BEEN HEARD.
SHOCK, SHOULDER, HIP YOUR TEETH
FINE I CAN SEE.
YOU STILL SMILE.
IS THERE ONE TIME, I HAVE TO
THIS.
THEY CAN UP CLOSE TO THESE
BOWLS, THEY ALL LOOK MEAN TO ME.
I'M AN ANIMAL LOVER BUT Y'ALL
ARE AND SCARY TO ME.
GIVE IT A SENSE WHEN YOU FINALLY
SIT ON ONE THAT IS HE TO BAD?
SOMETHING REALLY ANGRY OR NO TO
THE ALL SEEM THE SAME?
>> NOTE THEIR BREAD THAT HE
WOULD LIKE IN THE BACK.
NOW THAT WHEN THE JOB IS UP FOR
MY MENTALITY I NEVER GET ON WHEN
IT'S A OKRA.
YOU CAN COUNT ONE OF THESE
ANIMALS AND HAVE A DOUBT IN YOUR
MIND THAT'S CAN GO BAD OR SOME
LIKE THAT.
I THINK FOR ME THAT YOU'RE
SETTING YOURSELF UP FOR FAILURE,
SET MYSELF UP FOR SOMETHING GOOD
TO HAPPEN.
>> Laura: THANK GOD FOR THE
RODEO CLOWNS.
WHEN CAN WE WATCH YOU NEXT?
WHERE YOU COMPETING NEXT?
SHE GONNA TAKE A COUPLE WEEKENDS
OFF.
I CAN HAVE SOME TROUBLE GOING ON
WITH MY GROIN RIGHT NOW.
IT'LL PROBABLY BE IN DULUTH,
GEORGIA.
THE FOLLOWING WEEKEND.
>> Laura: TAKE CARE THAT
INJURY DALE AND SWEARINGEN ONE
AMAZING STORY IS ON THE COOLEST
AND MOST UNLIKELY OF BULL RIDING
STORIES AND WE WISH YOU THE VERY
BE